فعاليه بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
نراقب ما تقدمه ايران لروسيا في حربهم مع
اوكرانيا من مسيرات هذا هو مسار التركيز
وهذا مثال قلق دول كثيره في انحاء العالم
[موسيقى]
نعتقد ان الطريقه الاكثر فعاليه بالنسبه
لتعاطي الاسره الدوليه مع مع ايران نوويه
هي التي كانت موجوده دائما ولكن رئيس مصمم
على عدم امتلاك ايران وكافه الخيارات
مطروحه للطاوله لعدم وجود ذلك لكن خيرون
الافضل هو دبلوماسي بما في ذلك الوقت
نقف بجانب هؤلاء الذين تم قمهم خلال عام
العقوبات واجراءات التصنيفات المختلفه
ونسعى ايضا
ب90 لمساعده الشعب الايراني من خلال
تكنولوجيا الاتصالات
وسوف نستمر في ايجاد الخبيثه
[موسيقى]
انها علاقه ما تزال في قيد التطور وسوف
نعمل كل ما بوسه للتاكد من ان هذه العلاقه
تعكس مصالحنا واقي منه وهي مساله
دائما مستمره وليس وهي علاقه مستمره وكانت
لدينا بعض المخاوف حول القرار التي اتخذت
من قبل ذلك الحين كانت سعوديه اظهرت
علامات ايجابيه مثلا دعمها الواضح
لاكرانيا في وجهي الغزو الروسي الغاشم
[موسيقى]